the only Joker quotes why so serious
my life a movie treatment treatment
trash hey guys Greg this is Aaron
Alexander hey oh great friend of mine we
always talk about Marvel and DC stuff
have you seen the channel looper before
I've looped oh I've had some loop in my
life
we're watch the Batman fans already know
who they want as the next Joker
apparently they do
we're Batman fans yeah they nailed it
babe they know what all of y'all want
every single one of every single one
name what the one person well if anybody
knows anything the Internet is universe
let's watch whatever this pic is we'll
see if we agree and then we'll share our
thoughts to Cheryl my fans are quickly
falling a consensus opinion about who
they would like to see playing the next
Clown Prince of Crime the roster of
villains for the upcoming the Batman may
already be said and things only a matter
of time before the next o matic
incarnation of the Joker arrived to vex
Robert Pattinson Dark Knight the fan
favorite choice for the role will endure
fire who co-starred with Pattinson and
last year Robert Atkins directed
psychological horror flick the
lighthouse
[Music]
hundreds Switzer's fancy like in the
tempest and cleansers back to your
college funds have no say in casting
Hollywood productions you never know
reanimates on casting under w-4 why the
hell didn't we think of us because yeah
now that the notion of Dafoe as the
Joker is out there it certainly seems
like the definition of a no-brainer the
veteran at the mouth of a wiry
physicality which is perfect for the
role his facial structure and toothy
grin are also custom made the joke Adele
as evidenced by some twists force of her
fantasy of Instagram user the Sith Lord
Joker over the [ __ ] themselves up to
see will then play the faux of
Parkinson's Batman stage production with
Duran Pattinson continually one-upping
each other and the crazy Department and
the two actors intense chemistry have
lightbulbs popping and wide maybe we
could even set the scene for the idea
writing Willem Dafoe was joka in a
post-credits scene of the pump
[Music]
never come to fruition before I'll be
enough but turns out that the idea of
cutting their foes the Clown Prince of
Crime has been had before by the guy who
wrote the screenplay that would evolve
into Tim Burton's Batman in an abode The
Hollywood Reporter in 2018 the foe were
called that Sam ham who wrote the
initial drafts of Batman had talked him
up for the role of the Joker which of
course eventually went to Jack Nicholson
called ham says something about how
physically I would be perfect for the
part but they never occurred to me never
to be tho Defoe got his chance support
Raya cackling and hinge super villain
when he was cast as Norman Osborn's
Green Goblin I did mine in 2002 monitor
films like gave birth for the modern
superhero genre
[Music]
of course he absolutely crushed the role
well though he and steamroid said David
Koepp made the service they come and
serve warrants karo and have made with
Batman killing off the iconic villain in
his very first appearance since then the
focus if disturbing down here at Porto
Rico speed machines Aquaman in white he
popped up as a Tiffany characters friend
and adviser BOGO this would probably not
precluding potential sequels will be set
in a different universe than the main DC
EU timeline we would sure love for this
browser casting to come to fruition and
we hope the people in charge consider
for sure the year dream of melanoma hey
Warner Brothers you got the power to
make a bath buns the world over freak
out just by giving the guy a call how
about it I've heard the idea of Willem
Dafoe being the Joker before that's been
like a popular fan casting choice for
the Joker there are times where I'm like
really on board for it and times where
I'm not only because it just seems like
this might sound stupid it sounds like
too obvious of a choice back then when
Jack Nicholson was cast as the Joker
like that's an obvious choice and it
panned out great and I feel like there's
a sort of middle line that we look for
now with with specifically the character
of the Joker where we're like we want
someone that you can see doing it but
you wouldn't immediately imagine doing
it right that way there's a level of
subversion surprise expectation because
I feel like you kind of wouldn't know
what you're getting into with Willem
Dafoe and Joker granted there I mean he
really does have the features and the
characteristics and in a lot of ways
he's more obvious of a choice than Jack
Nicholson actually is Willem Dafoe is
that actor who I just wouldn't want to
be friends with he creeps me out I don't
want to get in that scaring contest if
he was ever to be in a romantic comedy
I'm
I don't watch it's like he's so great at
the sinister psychopathic
larger-than-life
I think being a Joker he would be great
and I think the idea of him bouncing off
of Robert Pattinson that would be
exciting because of their incredible
work together in the lighthouse and this
one I just remembered had Anson recently
said that he's basing some of his voice
for Batman the inspiration for it came
from what Willem Dafoe did in the
lighthouse really so this it kind of be
with this interesting complimentary yeah
it's a pirate and that's okay
I am perilous rates of yeah what do you
think it is a little obvious that he'd
be the one that people want to be the
Joker and I think he he'd be good
my only trepidation is the fact that
he's a lot older then Robert Pattinson
is and I know Batman and Joker don't
necessarily have to be like the same age
but they I thought this at least being
like the same sort of age range you know
because if he's gonna play the Joker for
years to come you want to still be able
to do that and have that physicality
even if they go on for like another 10
15 years and grant I don't know how foe
is but I feel like he will not be able
to bring that for a like another like 20
years of yeah of films which you might
necessarily have to I mean that's that's
right that's that's why walking Phoenix
played a 20 year old perfectly an
age-appropriate Batman grows up it makes
sense as they're talking about this I
think is someone to be interesting for
the role of the Joker which may be
another I guess obvious choice but I
don't think a lot of people are talking
about it would be uh Jake Gyllenhaal I
think Jake Gyllenhaal would make a
really good Joker it's not as obvious of
a choice but I mean you say you could
easily see it yeah itself scene stuff
like um jaw or Nightcrawler you guys
only have that physicality and he's plus
a lot younger you seen him transform
into like I mean it's Jake Gyllenhaal so
it's hard to make him look unattractive
but we transform it to like
creepy-looking dude yeah it's stuff like
Nightcrawler so I could see Jake
Gyllenhaal be a good pick for it I got a
weird one go for it mark
just complaining Jewish joke I got a
great one yeah Michael Cera
Michael Sara's dish I neurotic I did
like the thought of having like a
post-credits scene and seeing like
revealing Willem Dafoe as the Joker like
that does sound cool and I feel like for
a Batman franchise
you will need Joker in there at some
point I think it's really smart that
they're not kicking this off with Joker
and the Matt Reese version at least of
what we know they're not kicking off
with that maybe even weights like the
third film to have Joker I think would
be a cool way to build and to also
separate yourself from the joaquin
phoenix one because i'm not sure how
well audiences around the world who
don't really keep up with the
conversation and movie news and all that
are able to really pick up on what the
hell's going on like Joaquin Phoenix
plays Joker it's great wins Oscars makes
a billion dollars and then there's a
birds of prey movie then the clearly
referencing the Jared Leto Joker I don't
know if everyone's like oh yeah
obviously they're two different ones you
know there's a difference we got to get
people more credit than that I feel like
even if you're outside of the comic book
world you can still tell that dude and
purple suit is not nate'd with with the
blood smile we've also become accustomed
to linking the universes and having
everything being tied in so I think if
you have like another Joker so soon yeah
and even 20 times I'm thinking like gah
wait at least like 20 22 at the minimum
I hope they're gonna bring in with the
amount of money that Joker Joaquin
Phoenix has made like he did it by
himself with the amount of money that
one's made a sequel is probably
inevitable so I think they have to wait
until that movie comes out if that does
even happen at all for them to do
another Joker but I think with Matt
Reeves sort of cast the fact that
they've cast these people that you
wouldn't necessarily think of at first
but our talent on the
I feel like if they were to Casa Joker
it would go sort of in that kind of vein
and willem dafoe doesn't necessarily fit
that kind of mold
he's expected but then again if he got
the role I'm sure he'd knock it out the
park I wouldn't be mad if he got the
role but I don't think it would although
that photo photo is gonna give me
nightmares that's a pretty it's a pretty
scary photo that is yeah he's not coming
on my birthday party uninvite him now
lie and tell him that it was canceled
for those of you that are around in 2005
he's no longer in my fave 5 who goes who
understand t-mobile references if now
that's okay either time on MySpace yes
bad - you know myspace is no all right
guys what do you think of Willem Dafoe
is being joke or what is your pick leave
your thoughts down below subscribe to
the react nation click that notification
about subscribe a looper fault Erin
Alexander and last but not least patron
of the days shout out Austin Schneider I
don't know where John is I'm sorry he's
not in the video to improvise body
language but I got a caddy here today
who wants to get away
I just rhymed you know what that means
it's a poem for a patron of the day
turning and tossing as I'm thinking
about new patron his name is Austin got
me acting all giddily as his name
literally means magic dignity now that's
a name that's memorable but the other
meaning may be preferable for it implies
a great deal of respect the word is then
Vener venerable be narubu I toast a
glass of cider to a man more charming
than Rob Schneider his last name is
Schneider hold on I'm trying to shout
him out all the way from Washington as
cute as Paddington you're gonna stay
right here as a shout out Austin career
pursuits ignite my admiration hope you
measure every word for effect definition
adaptation that's right I looked it up
passion is to be a teacher he may be
soft but he's as lethal as Jack Reacher
I saw his profile pic he should be a
star and major No
features thanks for being here
Austin